es una nueva era en las relaciones entre
Francia y Reino Unido así lo definieron
el presidente de Francia Emanuel mazcon
y el Primer Ministro de Reino Unido
Richi sunak y
es un momento yo diría de reencuentro
reconexión y nuevo comienzo marca una
voluntad común de hablar entre nosotros
de coordinarnos mejor y de construir
juntos nuevas perspectivas
y es que en esta Cumbre que reunió a
empresarios importantes de ambos lados
del Canal de la Mancha los países
relanzaron sus relaciones bilaterales
tras años de roces debido al brexit con
el problema del protocolo de Irlanda del
Norte solucionado y la Guerra de Ucrania
de fondo Reino Unido y Francia tienen
muchos intereses en común entre estos la
migración o más bien cómo frenar la
llegada irregular de migrantes a las
costas británicas después de registrar a
más de 45.000 personas en 2022 para lo
que Londres pagará 577 millones millones
de dólares a París
hoy hemos llevado a nuestra cooperación
a un nivel sin precedentes para hacer
frente a un desafío compartido
anunciamos un nuevo centro de detención
en el norte de Francia un nuevo centro
de mando que reunirá por primera vez a
nuestros equipos encargados de hacer
cumplir la ley
otro de los grandes anuncios fue un
pacto nuclear de cooperación civil y en
materia de defensa que entrenarán a
Marines ucranianos coordinarán sus
portaaviones en el lindo Pacífico y
cooperarán en desarrollo armamentístico
en la cop 27 de Egipto Solo dos semanas
después de que sunak juramentara ya se
vio cercanía entre los mandatarios algo
que algunos tabloides británicos
llegaron a catalogar como lebromans Y
esta es la primera reunión de las
Naciones miembros permanentes del
Consejo de Seguridad de la ONU y ambas
potencias nucleares en cinco años